The negotiation of the new pact on
migration and asylum is facing its
decisive hour. We must choose in which Europe we
want to live: the Europe of the walls
defended by Mr. Beber and the extreme
right, or the humanist Europe that does not
close its eyes to the loss of
human lives.  in the xenophobic Europe that lashes
immigrants or in the Europe of
law that wants immigrants
for the development of our societies
and our cultures in the Europe of
fear of the different or in the Europe of
hope that works to find a
solution  but it will not be the walls that will
improve our coexistence, but the
union of our forces to manage
the arrival of immigrants according to the
possibilities of each state and
respect for legality now that the
extreme right accuses the Lord of
copying his model of Europe against
immigration in the
social democratic family we direct our gaze
to that other soul of the popular party that
is willing to take to protect to
integrate the walls and nationalisms
push us to devastating consequences
let's overcome the fear of being different let's make
Europe a meeting place for
diverse peoples  a land of peace,
progress and opportunities, protecting
first and foremost the lives of every man and
woman because the future of Europe
will only be prosperous if we reconcile
with the most vulnerable no y european
Money to build